it's I want to put it like I went  through  such a traumatic thing as a teenager  so I went through so many traumatic  experiences that I  I  learned from them you didn't become  closed off yeah it's like I could have  but  I just I'm just full of love at the end  of the day I don't want to hate nobody I  don't want to do anybody wrong and  like I have so much heart which is um I  don't understand why but  it's like I think of the little girl  inside of me like the child like just  like she just wants to be loved so at  the end of the day I'm just gonna give  love I'm not  gonna like  be closed off from everybody or be mad  at everybody or just spread negativity I  went through these experiences for a  reason